je vous souhaite la bienvenue et je vous
remercie vivement de vous être rendu
disponible pour nous faire part de votre
témoignage nous avons entamé les travaux
de notre commission d'enquête sur
l'identification des défaillances de
fonctionnement au sein des fédérations
françaisees de sport du monde sportif et
des organismes de gouvernance du monde
sportif le 20 juillet dernier
l'Assemblée nationale a choisi de créer
cette commission d'enquête à la suite de
très nombreuses révélations publiqu de
sportifs et sportives dont le vôtre et
de divers scandales judiciaire ayant
trait à la gestion de certaines
fédérations nos travaux se déclinent
donc autour de trois axes
l'identification des violences physique
sexuell ou psychologique dans le sport
l'identification des discriminations
sexuelles et raciales dans le sport et
l'identification des problématique lié à
la gouvernance financière des
fédérations sportives et des organismes
de gouvernance du monde sportif
bénéficiant d'une délégation de service
public nous nous sommes nous vous sommes
pardon très reconnaissants d'avoir
accepté de nous faire part de votre
expérience lors de cette audition étant
donné le courage que cela requiert vous
avez dénoncé l'effet de violence de la
part de votre entraîneur de tennis
monsieur Andrew GATS qui s'est avéré est
un prédateur sexuel Magnant la
manipulation
psychologique vous avez ainsi été
humilié et violé près de 400 fois
lorsque vous aviez entre 12 et 14 ans et
vous avez dénoncé le règne de l'omerta
de la part de votre entourage dans le
monde du tennis presque 15 ans plus tard
avec d'autres victimes du même prédateur
sexuel vous avez réussi à dénoncer ces
viols qui ont conduit à la réclusion
criminelle de cet entraîneur pour une
durée de 18 ans puis vous avez créé
l'association rebond pour conduire des
interventions de prévention et de
sensibilisation auprès des club et de la
Ligue ainsi que de la formation et de
l'aide aux victimes pouvez-vous nous
expliquer votre calvaire à l'époque le
cheminement que vous avez suivi jusqu'à
votre plainte et les conséquences de ces
violences sur votre santé physique et
mental depuis pour nous permettre de
comprendre la gravité de ces faits
pouvez-vous également
présenter votre association et nous
indiquer les mesures qui selon vous
devraient être mis en place pour lutter
contre de telles pratiques je rappelle
que cette audition est ouverte à la
presse et qu'elle est retransmise en
direct sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale avant de vous laisser la
parole et d'entamer nos échanges pendant
environ 1 heure je vous rappelle que
l'article 6 de ordonnance du 17 novembre
1958 relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires impose aux
personnes entendues par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure après
avoir activé votre micro je vous
remercie euh je le
jure je vous remercie et vous avez la
parole tout d'abord je voulais vous
remercier vous aussi d'avoir créé cette
commission et de vous soucier de ce fléo
qui touche le sport mais pas que voilà
je vais me présenter donc je m'appelle
angélique Kosi j'ai 36 ans et
aujourd'hui je suis professeur de PS et
j'habite dans le sud-ouest de la France
à
Bayonne j'ai commencé le tennis à 4 ans
alors je suis d'une famille ma mère est
espagnole et elle a vécu des violences
sexuelles quand elle était plus jeune
enfin sa maman s'est fait violer devant
elle quand elle était très jeune et j'ai
grandi avec cette image
elle me l'a raconté quand j'étais toute
petite et j'ai tout de suite eu une
relation où j'étais plutôt la mère de ma
mère elle était très fragile elle avait
des traumatismes qu'elle a pas réussi à
régler et mon père est quelqu'un du Nord
de la France qui parle peu qui est pas
très démonstratif et qui disait pas je
t'aime et moi j'étais une enfant qui
avait besoin de beaucoup de
reconnaissance j'étais HPI HPE au
potentiel intellectuel et émotionnel et
voilà j'avais de l'avance à l'école je
donc j'attendais qu'on dise toujours que
c'était bien j'essayais d'être la petite
fille parfaite et et j'avais j'avais
besoin du regard des autres et donc j'ai
commencé le tennis parce que j'allais en
Espagne en vacances et il y avait un
prof de tennis à la plage qui avait dit
à mes parents inscrivaient là elle a
l'air super doué donc je m'étais
inscrite et rapidement j'ai joué avec
des garçons de 12 ans parce qu'il y
avait pas de fille de mon niveau dans
mon club et à 7 ans j'ai été prise par
la Ligue du valdoise donc qui m'a de
fourniss des des entraînements
supplémentaires et qui donnit une bourse
dans mon club pour que je puisse
m'entraîner davantage et que ça coûte
pas trop cher à mes parents estce que ma
mère ne travaillait pas et mon père
était fonctionnaire de police donc on
était pas particulièrement aisé et donc
voilà j'ai j'ai continué à jouer jusqu'à
mes 12 ans dans ce club là et à 12 ans
j'ai dû changer de club parce que
c'était pas un assez gros club et donc
j'avais le choix entre deux clubs auon
et sarcell et auon c'était le club où il
y avait entre guillemets mes rivales et
le tennis c'est un sport individuel où
on nous montre quand même très
rapidement les uns contre les autres
c'est très difficile pour des enfants
d'être c'est c'est un sport difficile
parce qu'on est seul et donc je suis
allée dans l'autre club Sarcel et donc
je devais m'entraîner avec avec le
directeur sportif qui cette année-là a
une promotion est devenu entraîneur
fédéral à la Ligue de scène saint-ni
Patrick Bouteiller donc finalement c'est
pas lui qui m'a entraîné c'est l'autre
entraîneur Andrew Guedes qui au début
était très gentil qui avait un peu un
rôle de de copain ou grands frèr et moi
je souffrais dans ma famille de de
sortir peu de pas aller au cinéma de pas
aller être dans des musées de pas aller
voir des concerts mes parents étaient
pas très curieux ils avaient pas fait
d'études et moi j'étais en en recherche
de découvrir le monde et lui m'a apporté
ça parce que voilà il m'a offert un
atlas du monde très rapidement et je
passais mes soirées à regarder la
densité de population de tous les pays à
prendre toutes les superficies par cœur
et et il m'a amené voir des match du PSG
j'étais fan du PSG et c'est comme ça que
ça a commencé parce que j'étais jamais
allé au Parc des Princes et le seul la
seule image que j'avais du Parc des
Princes c'était mon père qui était CRS
et qui me disait que lui il passait son
temps à regarder les tribunes et il
pouvait pas trop regarder de match mais
il me racontait un petit peu l'ambiance
et donc moi je regardais ça avec mes
yeux en me disant j'aimerais tellement y
aller et donc quand cet entraîneur m'a
proposer mes parents ils ont vu dans mes
yeux tellement tellement d'envie de
vivre des choses qui m'ont qui m'ont pas
qui m'ont pas interdit ils ont dit
d'accord et la première fois ça s'est
très bien passé il m'a ramené chez moi
et puis au fur et à mesure il a commencé
à dire il faudrait qu'elle s'entraîne
davantage et j'entraîne dans un deuxième
club à côté de chez moi les gens sont
meilleurs je peux venir l'entraîner je
vous la ramène et donc j'étais de plus
en plus seul avec lui dans les
transports ou sur des des lieux qui
étaient pas à mon club et puis une fois
il a dit à mes parents ça serait plus
pratique qu'elle dorme à la maison parce
que ça fait loin pour moi de la ramener
après et mes parents ont fait confiance
parce qu'ils ont pas vu le mal et euh la
première fois il s'est rien passé il m'a
laissé sa chambre il a dormi dans le
salon et puis en fait ça ça c'est petit
à petit c'est devenu quasiment comme un
rituel que après les entraînements un
peu tardifs dans son deème club oou
après les matchs de foot bah je restais
chez lui dormir et en fait il a pris
possession de la programmation de notre
tournoi ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
quand on est un jeune joueur de tennis
ont fait beaucoup beaucoup de matchs et
je faisais 125 matchs par an en plus de
ma scolarité ça fait l'quip équivalent
d'un match tous les 3 jours et donc mon
père il était le seul à conduire et
c'était une grosse charge pour lui de
devoir gérer mes entraînements mes
matchs et ceux de ma petite sœur qui
avait 2 ans de moins et qui jou aussi au
tennis donc ça a été un soulagement pour
ma famille quand il s'est proposé de
m'inscrire dans des tournoi et de m'y
emmener et voilà il y a un soir où il
est resté il m'a demandé s'il pouvait me
raconter une histoire j'ai trouvé ça un
petit peu bizarre j'avais quand même 12
ans j'en avais pas 5 et j'ai dit il a
pas d'enfant peut-être qu'il a besoin
d'affection peut-être que il voudrait
que je sois comme sa fille et puis la
fois d'après il est resté un peu plus
longtemps puis après il me demandait si
je pouvais lui caresser le dos et puis
il me prenait dans ses bras et en fait
ça s'est fait tellement petit à petit
que j'ai je savais que tout ça était pas
normal j'étais très mal à l'aise je
voulais pas que ça arrive mais je savais
pas à quel moment il fallait que je dise
stop et j'étais j'étais seule loin de
chez moi à 30 km et à 12 ans on on n pas
capable de s'opposer physiquement et
psychologiquement à un adulte d'autant
plus si c'est quelqu'un qu'on respecte
et qu'on admire
et surtout si on pense que cette
personne va nous aider à peut-être
accéder à nos rêves alors il faut savoir
que quand je suis arrivé au club de
Sarcel à 12 ans j'avais pas du tout
envie d'être joueuse professionnel moi
je je voulais faire science
polena et donc voilà le monde du tennis
pour moi c'était j'étais dans les trois
quatre meilleurs joueus françaises mais
je me voyais pas êre joueuse
professionnelle et lui m'a
m'a a mis cette graine en fait à me dire
que j'avais le potentiel que je pouvais
largement être dans les 10 meilleurs
mondiales seniors que j'avais du talent
j'étais gauchère revers à une main
j'étais grande que j'étais plus
intelligente que la moyenne sur interin
de tennis et cetera et au fur et à
mesure des entraînements ça prend
tellement une part importante qu'on se
détache aussi de ce qui est la vie d'un
adolescent classique et moi quand
j'étais au collège j'étais un peu perdu
je savais pas qui était friends
euh je voilà j'avais rien en commun avec
ceux qui étaient avec moi à l'école
parce que j'allais en classe en plus
voilà j'étais beaucoup plus jeune qu'eux
ils avaient 2 ans de retard moi j'avais
des années d'avance donc on était quand
même c'était un monde qui nous séparait
et moi je sortais des cours et je
sortais en courant pour que mon père me
récupère et m'emmène m'entraîner jusqu'à
20h30 puis je rentrais chez moi et
c'était ça tout le temps et les weekends
j'avais les tournois donc j'étais
j'étais vite seule aussi au collège et
cet isolement participe aussi à à
au fait de violence que peuvent subir
des jeunes comme ça dans les dans les
milieux sportifs parce que c'est comme
moi aujourd'hui je suis professeur de PS
voilà comme le
harcèlement quand un enfant est seul il
est il est beaucoup plus facilement une
proie et je pense qu'il a vu que j'étais
une proie facile entre guillemets pour
plein de raisons parce que j'avais une
faille de reconnaissance que j'avais pas
de ma famille parce que j'avais besoin
de de de découvrir le monde une
curiosité que mes parents n'arrivaient
pas à satisfaire euh parce que j'avais
besoin d'être si c'était possible
parfaite la meilleure possible en tout
cas et c'était il pouvait me pousser
très loin physiquement et
psychologiquement et j'étais capable
d'encaisser et cette exigence aussi
finalement s'est retourné contre moi si
j'avais pas
euh accepté tout ça euh par envie de
bien faire bah peut-être qu'il aurait
choisi quelqu'un d'autre mais donc voilà
et puis un jour il m'a plaqué contre le
couloir de en face de sa salle de de
bain il m'a embrassé sur la bouche et là
ça m'a fait un choc j'étais j'étais
sidéré ça ça s'est fait en quelques mois
en même pas de TR mois et je lui ai dit
non il faut pas c'est pas bien moi je
veux pas et il me dit mais quoi tu sais
ça arrive souvent les relations
entraîneur entraînés on passe tellement
de temps ensemble c'est normal les gens
peuvent pas comprendre mais ça arrive
souvent et moi je voulais pas du tout il
avait l'âge de ma mère enfin moi j'avais
ma seule expérience cétait l'été d'avant
j'étais tombée amoureuse entre
guillemets
du grand frère d'Adrian manarino qui est
un joueur de tennis qui s'appelle Morgan
et au bout de 3 semaines a passé notre
temps ensemble on s'était tenu la main
donc c'était un peu ça mon expérience
et et
donc il m'a dit c'est rien et moi
j'étais tétanisée 10 minutes après dans
l'ascenseur il m'a réembrassé et je me
suis pas opposée physiquement et là j'ai
su que ça allait être compliqué de m'en
sortir et en fait j'ai jamais rien dit à
mes parents parce que j'aurais pu
peut-être le dire à ce moment-là après
c'était certainement trop tard mais à ce
moment-là j'aurais peut-être pu le dire
mais mon père il nous dis qu'il parlait
jamais c'est quelqu'un du Nord nous
disait tout le temps si un jour
quelqu'un vous fait du mal j'attendrai
pas que justice soit faite je lu mettrai
une balle entre les deux yeux qui
t'apprendre 20 ans de tôle et c'est
quelque chose qui m'a tellement marqué
et j'ai tellement grandi avec cette arme
qui ramenait de voilà qui laissait dans
la cuisine et je savais où elle était je
savais qu'il fallait pas la toucher je
l'ai jamais touché que c'était quelque
chose de réel je savais que
potentiellement ça pouvait arriver je me
disais il dit certainement ça mais il le
fera peut-être pas mais même si c'était
1 % de risque qu'il le fasse c'était
impossible que je prenne le risque que
mon père fasse de la prison parce qu'il
avait tué quelqu'un que ma mère qui
était déjà fragile part en hôpital
psychiatrique et que ma petite sœur et
moi en partant en foyer donc je me suis
dit il va falloir que je m'en sorte
seule et ça m'a pris 2 ans et avant mes
13 ans il m'avait déjà violé
digitalement avec le
pénis et en fait c'est ce que j'ai dit à
la barre c'est assez bizarre et étonnant
de le dire mais je préférais
l'effilation parce que ça me faisait pas
mal donc si c'était possible je faisais
une fation si c'était un endroit où je
savais que j'allais il y avait une
possibilité pour qu'il se fasse prendre
bah j'essayais de perdre du temps pour
que ça se passe pas et si c'était chez
lui ou dans un endroit clos bah je le
faisais le plus vite possible pour que
ça soit terminé
mais sur le coup on se rend r compte de
répercussion que ça va avoir toute notre
vie sur notre construction la seule
chose qu'on essaie de faire c'est de
survivre et voilà j'avais un petit
carnet avec les autographes des joueurs
du PSG parce que j'allais les voir au
Camp des Loges et entre ces feuilles
j'écrivais j'en peux plus il faut que ça
cesse je vais faire que tout s'arrête et
j'ai pensé tellement de fois à me
suicider et à chaque fois j'arrachais la
feuille et je disais non faut pas que ma
mère complètement maniaque qui fouille
notre chambre toutes les 2 secondes
tombe dessus donc j'arrachais la feuille
et je la dépioté en petits morceau et je
l'ai jetais dans toutes les poubelles du
trajet qui m'emmenait au collège il y
avait 867 pas parce que j'ai développé
un toc de comptage où pour me rassurer
je compte tout tout le temps aujourd'hui
je compte le nombre de coup de raclette
que je mets dans la douche c'est neuf le
17 expiration sur 100 m de footing enfin
c'est c'est quelque chose voilà qui m'a
permis de me raccrocher à ce que je
pouvais maîtriser parce que je
maîtrisais plus rien
et et en fait je suis parti à la B au
mois de juillet donc c'était finalement
il lui est originaire de la ballle et en
fin de compte j'ai appris au cours du
procès que c'était un petit peu son
mécanisme parce qu'à chaque fois il a
amené ses ses victimes à La Baule loin
de loin de chez elle complètement
déraciné pour passer à des stades
supérieurs entre guillemets
alors moi pendant ces 15 jours-l ça a
été les 15 pires jours de ma vie je il
m'a violé trois fois par jour le premier
soir il m'a demandé d'aller dans sa
chambre et j'y suis pas allé et donc il
est venu dans la mienne et ça a été pire
parce
que j'étais prisionnère je pouvais pas
partir quand je voulais et après j'étais
obligé rester dans l'endroit où ça
s'était passé et pour moi c'est c'était
vraiment je me sentais tellement sale et
donc les soirs d'après ça paraît fou
mais j'y suis allée de moi-même et j'ai
fait ces 13 pas qui me séparaient de sa
chambre pour pour aller me faire violer
et c'est l'année où le Concorde s'est
écrasé fin juillet et je me disais c'est
marrant moi aussi je suis en train de
m'écraser et j'avais pas encore mes
règles et j'ai eu mes règles le 5 août
suivant en Espagne en vacances et il est
venu en vacances sur mon lieu de
vacances pour pas me laisser respirer il
avait dit à mes parents que c'était une
surprise et il est venu avec sa petite
copine parce qu'il avait une copine de
son âge
et ma mère lui a dit elle lui a dit
innocemment parce que ma mère c'est un
peu une enfant et puis elle lui a dit
aussi peut-être l'air de dire bah elle
est en train de grandir physiquement
elle va peut-être changer mais elle lui
a dit que j'avais eu mes règles et lui
quelques jours plus tard dans l'eau il
m'a dit ah c'est bien tu deviens plus
grande je vais pouvoir faire plus de
choses mais va falloir que je fasse
gaffe et dans ma tête je me suis dit
mais qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire de plus
et en fin de compte malheureusement pas
pour moi mais pour les autres il a fait
tellement
pire en en terme sexuel c'est que moi
euh bon ben voilà moi je me suis pas
fait moi il m'a pas mis de
cuillère en bois dans le vagin moi il
m'a pas laissé nu dans la forêt
plusieurs
heures des choses qu'ont pu vivre
certaines de mes
covictimes donc quelque part je suis
plutôt chanceuse de ce côté-là mais mais
par contre psychologiquement ça m'a
détruite aussi parce que il disait des
choses il me disait qu'il avait le sida
qu' l' il me l'avait donné et à la fin
des années 80 90 c'était ça faisait un
petit peu plus peur que maintenant et
moi j'ai vécu entre 13 et 18 ans en
pensant que j'avais le sida et quand
j'ai eu mon permis et je suis allée
toute seule chez le médecin pour la
première fois parce que j'avais une
maman très mèpoule qui m'accompagnait
jusqu'à mes 18 ans chez le médecin et
j'avais demandé s'il pouvait me faire
des des analyses parce que j'étais un
peu fatiguée avec tout le sport les
études et donc il a dit oui je vous fais
le faire les vitamines et ce je lui dis
oh vous pouvez aussi me mettre le HIV à
tout hasard et moi j'étais persuadé que
je l'avais et je me souviendrai toujours
devant cette pcarte marquée parking
réservé à la clientèle dans ma c tibisa
que mes grands-parents m'avaient offert
j'ouvre le papier et c'est marqué
négatif et en fait non j'avais pas le
sida et lui il l'a jamais eu et il l'a
fait croire à chacune de nous
donc il disait qu'il allait tuer mes
parents comme ça au moins il pourrait
être tranquille avec moi il me disait
s'il te reste une semaine à vivre
qu'est-ce que tu fais je disais bah je
sais pas je passe du temps avec ma
famille il me dit moi je vais acheter
une arme et je tire sur tout le monde
enfin c'était tellement de violence il a
déjà frappé des gens qui soi-disant me
regardaient dans la voiture un poids
lourd sur laa86 il y avait trop de monde
à Nanterre on était en bouchon et il est
sorti de la voiture avec une batte de
baseball et il a dit qu'il allait lui
casser la gueule parce qu'il a il était
en train de regarder mes jambes alors
que pas du tout il conduisait qu'avec
les
genoux il se droguait il me laissait à
la Cité Pablo Picasso pour aller
s'acheter sa drog et moi j'étais
tétanisée dans la voiture et je
regardais les rétroviseurs sans arrêt
pour savoir si quelqu'un allait me
kidnapper ou j'en sais rien quoi j'avais
peur mais j'étais
terrifiée
et et en fait j'ai essayé la deuxième
année de m'en sortir en essayant d'aller
le moins souvent possible chez lui je
demandais à mon père de m'inscrire dans
des tournois proches de chez moi j'ai
demandé à m'entraîner plus souvent à la
Ligue pour moins m'entraîner avec lui et
au fur et à mesure j'ai j'ai réussi à
sortir un petit peu de cette emprise
mais il faut savoir que je m'habillais
comme lui m'achetais les mêmes habits
que lui j'étais son mini lui je mettais
ma casquette à l'envers comme lui je
j'avais des habits qui m'allaient trois
fois trop grands parce que il me donnait
ses
habits je mangeais ma pizza comme lui
c'està-dire que je mangeais plus mes
bord de pizza alors que j'adore la
croûte des pizzas mais j'étais devenu
un une marionnette j'était son esclave
sexuel j'ai il faisait ce qu'il voulait
de moi et
c'est à chaque fois je me disais j'avais
la peur au ventre en me disant je peux
mourir dans l'heure qui suit ce
sentiment d'insécurité aujourd'hui j'ai
36 ans et je vais mieux que depuis
janvier euh janvier j'ai décidé d'aller
voir un psychiatre pour la première fois
et ça va quand même beaucoup mieux mais
voilà j'ai le jour de mes 14 ans ma mère
m'a offert un nouveau téléphone un 3310
bleu ciel Nokia avec le jeu du serpent
pour ceux qui sont de ma génération
c'était une passion et et je me suis
promis de jamais répondre à son numéro
de téléphone 0609 411 88 c'est un numéro
j'iraai dans ma tombe avec je des fois
je donne son numéro à la place du mien
et et j'ai réussi à plus jamais répondre
et il a essayé pendant 15 jours de
m'appeler et quand il a vu que je
répondais plus il est passé à autre
chose et il a pris une autre victime et
elle s'appelait Astrid et je la
connaissait et ça s'est fait sous mes
yeux
et le plus dur pour moi à vivre c'est de
me dire que je les ai pas sauvé c'est
que j'ai dû faire le choix à 12 ans de
sauver ma famille et de pas les sauver
elle et que si j'avais parlé il y aurait
pas eu les autres victimes et ça c'est
c'est ça c'est ce qu'il y a de plus dur
vraiment
elle me dit sans arrêt tu avais 12 ans
c'est c'était pas un choix à faire tu
pouvais rien faire c'était pas à toi de
le faire mais il n'empêche
qu'aujourd'hui
j'essaye j'essaie de faire le bien
d'être prof de PS pour essayer d'être
une une adulte qui porte les enfants à à
s'élever sans être sans être manipulé
sans être sous emprise et j'espère que
le jour où je mourrais j'aurais fait
plus de bien que que le fait de pas les
avoir sauvé que ça me ça me soulagera un
petit
peu et surtout je remercie quand même
tous les jours en me levant la petite
fille de 12 ans que j'étais d'avoir
choisi la vie et de m'avoir permis de
rencontrer ma femme et d'avoir un fils
elle a été très forte la petite de 12
ans que j'étais
et je suis un petit peu morte à 12 ans
mais c'est un petit peu grâce à elle que
je suis là
aujourd'hui merci merci merci très
sincèrement pour ce très beau témoignage
beau parce qu'il vient de vous hein
j'entends
euh voilà c'est assez bouleversant
c'est c'est en tout
cas en c'est un témoignage qui
certainement aussi nous motive à avancer
aussi dans cette commission enquête et
qui fera que on souhaite que ça ne se
reproduise plus
jamais que vous petite fille que vous
étiez à 12 ans et bien vous vous auriez
eu le droit à une autre enfance très
certainement et et h et donc du fond du
cœur moi je vous
remercie merci beaup d'avoir ce courage
attention ce courage de bien N voir ben
merci beaucoup j'ai mis beaucoup de
temps à parler à vrai dire je l'aurais
peut-être jamais fait si Astrid en
question m'avait pas appelé à 27 ans en
me disant je suis à 4 jours de la
prescription moi il m'a violé et avec
une autre victime on pense que toi aussi
est-ce que c'est le cas et j'en avais
jamais parlé à part à mes petites amis
euh parce
que bah parce que je supporte pas la
pénétration parce que je peux pas faire
un frotti chez le gynéco j'ai ce qu'on
appelle un vaginisme
sévère donc j'étais bien obligé quand
même d'en parler à mes petites amis mais
je leur disais je me suis fait agresser
quand j'étais jeune et j'arrivais même
pas à mettre le mot viol dessus et à 27
ans je leur ai dit oui moi aussi mais je
sais pas si je suis prête je sais pas si
je peux le dire à mes parents je sais
pas si je peux changer comme ça ma vie
et donc j'ai mis 3 mois à réfléchir et
je me suis dit bah si c'est soit il va
maintenant soit il va jamais et je
pensais que avec moi elles auraient plus
de chance d'être entendu parce que c'est
terrible mais elles avaient entre 15 et
18 ans et j'avais peur que on puisse
penser qu'elles pouvait être consentante
parce qu'elles avaient 16
ans parce qu'en fait dans le milieu du
tennis ça se savait qu'il
était pas correct avec les filles les
jeunes filles je parle pas de moi parce
que pour moi ça s'est pas su euh mais
pour les autres il y en avait toujours
qui disaient oui il est avec il sort
avec mais enfin quand on a 38 ans on
sort pas avec une jeune de 15 ans encore
moins quand on l'entraîne enfin c'est là
il y avait une méconnaissance de la loi
quand on a autorité sur quelqu'un sur un
mineur enfin ça paraît fou parce que on
a laissé faire des choses dans le milieu
du sport qu'on qu'on transposerait dans
un autre milieu on dirait ça ne peut pas
arriver
enfin jamais on dirait ouai elle sort
avec son prof de math enfin ça ça paraît
fou mais c'est la même chose la
l'autorité est exactement la même si ce
n'est que c'est encore pire parce que il
nous voit en dehors d'un cadre
institutionnel où on vous voit
l'enseignant où on est plusieurs on est
rarement seul face à un enseignant alors
que là on passe notre temps seul avec
l'entraîneur on partage un quotidien de
tournois de
repas on partage nos doutes on partage
nos nos histoires qui peuvent se passer
au collèg ège et donc ça a tendance un
jeune il peut vite confondre les
frontières parce que il est pas du tout
armé c'est pas à lui de de mettre les
les les barrières
et et donc j'ai parlé à 27 ans mais ça a
été compliqué parce que voilà ça a été
très dur pour mes parents ma mère est
tombée en dépression elle a été
hospitalisée en hôpital psychiatrique
ils ont pas pu être là pour moi j'ai
essayé d'être là pour eux pendant 2 ans
et c'était trop dur donc j'ai j'ai j'ai
dû arrêter de les voir et de leur parler
pendant pendant plus de 2 ans et quelque
part on m'a
volé plein de P de ma vie c'està-dire
que on m'a volé peut-être ma carrière
que j'aurais pu avoir parce que après
j'ai fait toujours des choix qui
allaient m'amener à ne pas me retrouver
seule avec un adulte qui avait une
autorité sur moi donc j'ai refusé
d'aller au centre national
d'entraînement à 14 ans à Roland Garos
parce que j'avais peur de me retrouver
dans la même situation et à 17 enfin
j'ai eu mon bac à 16 ans à 16 ans on m'a
proposé les meilleures universités à la
fac américaine parce que j'avais des
très bons résultats à l'école que
j'avais eu le bac avec montion très bien
et que j'avais des années d'avance et
que j'étais dans les meilleures
Françaises donc on m'a proposé des
bonnes universités et c'est terrible
parce que j'ai dit non parce que j'avais
peur d'être
loin et donc je suis partie à la fac à
Paris 5 voilà Porte de Versailles et
j'ai fait trois masters et en même temps
j'ai passé mon BE1 mon be2 j'ai fait
plein d'études en même temps mais
quelque part peut-être que c'était pas
ça qui m'était destiné à la base et lui
voulait il disait toujours plus tard tu
feras Science Po et et du coup j'ai pas
fait Science Po parce que je voulais pas
faire ce que lui voulait que je fasse et
les trois autres ont fait Science Po
donc c'est quand même parce qu'elles
l'ont rencontré aussi entre 15 et 18 ans
donc c'était au moment où elles avaient
ce choix à faire et moi j'ai eu tout le
temps du lycée pour me séparer de
ça mais quelque part c'est aussi un
deuil parce que que aujourd'hui
intellectuellement je je je m'épanouis
pas professionnellement j'adore les
enfants et je fais ça pour eux
heureusement qu'ils sont là mais je
trouve que je je réfléchis pas assez
dans mon quotidien et bon c'est voilà
mais après j'ai que 36 ans je me dis que
peut-être que la vie est encore longue
et voilà que j'ai pu mes règles du jour
au lendemain quand j'ai déposé plainte
et j'ai perdu 25 kg j'en ai repris 30
j'en ai perd du vin j'en ai repris
35 en fait j'avais des crises de bouimie
terribles comme j'ai peur de me faire
vomi c'est ma phobie avec les oiseaux du
coup bah je me faisais jamais vomir et
et après quand j'étais dans ma phase où
je contrôle tout bah je je retirais une
pâte crue de ma balance si ça faisait
pas pile ce que j'avais prévu de manger
les 60 g de de pâte crue euh jeallais
courir 2hures tous les jours je courais
150 km par semaine enfin c'est cétait je
pense que je courrais pour fuir mon
passé en même temps pour essayer de
courir après mon futur je sais pas s'il
y avait quelque chose un peu d'imager
derrière tout ça en tout cas ça me
faisait du bien de me dépenser et de
penser à autre chose et j'ai eu un zona
la première fois que j'ai une
confrontation avec lui avec le juge
d'instruction et pendant les procès j'ai
saigné du nez 10 fois par jour donc ça a
été quand même très éprouvant mais ce
qui est important et en fait quand on le
vit l'instruction on se dit c'est
tellement long on voudrait tellement que
ça aille beaucoup plus vite mais en fait
c'est tellement nécessaire en 2014 quand
j'ai déposer plainte s'il y avait eu le
procès 6 mois plus tard j'aurais été
incapable d'être aussi clair je pense et
il faut ce temps qui est le temps de la
justice et parfois les victimes voudrait
que ça aille beaucoup plus vite mais
c'est nécessaire ça prend beaucoup de
temps à digérer tout ça et que la
famille les amis digèrent tout ça que la
société aussi parce que l'œil le regard
de la société chance je suis passée deun
joueuse de tennis et entraîneur de
tennis à la fille qui s'est fait violer
et je ne suis pas que ça mais il faut
assumer quand même cette image et moi
j'étais encore dans le milieu du tennis
qui n'était pas le cas des trois autres
donc ça peut-être était aussi un frein
au fait que c'est pas moi qui a parlé la
première parce qu'il y a tout de même
une enfin du moins en 2014 il y avait
encore une omerta sur ce sujet-là et ça
se savait qu'il y avait plein
d'entraîneurs qui avaient eu des
relations sexuelles non consenties avec
avec des mineurs mais on fermait les
yeux on disait que c'était pas à nous de
régler ça que ça nous regardait pas et
pour ma
part il y a une fois où j'ai étéis
enfermé dans le local de de bal au
sous-sol du club et c'était pendant ma
semaine de stage d'adaptation de de
stage d'entreprise de 3e il m'avait
demandé pour passer une semaine que je
choisisse mon stage chez lui moi je
voulais faire mon stage à l'Assemblée
nationale et euh et et donc j'avais
passé ma semaine à à voir comment se
passait la vie d'un club que je
connaissais par cœur mais et et donc
j'étais enfermé dans ce fameux local et
il m'avait demandé une fation et il y a
le barman du club qui était descendu à
ce moment-là qui avait essayé d'ouvrir
la porte et il avait pas réussi il avait
dit il y a quelqu'un il y a quelqu'un et
lui il m'avait mis la main sur la bouche
j'avais pas parlé et il était remonté et
15 minutes après mon entraîneur Andre
Guedes était remonté et moi encore 5
minutes après avec les yeux rouges et il
m'a pas posé la question il m'a pas dit
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé où tu étais on
était trois dans le club lui
l'entraîneur et moi moi ça me paraît
totalement fou de me dire aujourd'hui
que ça puisse se passer et que un adulte
ne prenne pas la responsabilité
d'alerter le président du club la Ligue
et même le procureur enfin c'est enfin
je pense qu'il y avait quand même je
sais pas si c'était une méconnaissance
de la non assistance
ou mais on laissait on préférait fermer
les yeux et ça c'est terrible parce que
les les enfants il peuvent pas se se
sauver seul donc moi je me disais aussi
si les gens ferment les yeux c'est
peut-être parce que c'est normal alors
moi je trouvais pas ça normal mais
finalement qui pose la norme qui pose
les valeurs c'est c'est les adultes
donc il se passait plein de choses dans
le club qui aurait dû être normalement
prise en compte enfin un entraîneur il
il insulte pas ses ses élèves ça
n'arrive pas et là ça arrivait tous les
jours sur les terrains de tennis c'était
tous les jours qui disait au petit gamin
de 10 ans tu es qu'un péd ta pète tu vas
pas t'en sortir
euh des trucs totalement fou j'ai une
tellement longue qu'on pourrait
m'en faire une écharpe enfin c'est c'est
ça ça paraît fou mais c'est ce qui
c'était notre quotidien et on vivait
dans ça
et on peut pas tolérer enfin si on le
transpose ailleurs à l'école ou dans la
musique enfin on a tendance à être
beaucoup plus permissif quand c'est dans
le milieu sportif et j'en ai encore
parlé la semaine dernière avec une maman
où son fils fait du rugby elle me dit oh
tu sais le milieu du rugby c'est comme
ça mais non c'est pas comme ça enfin il
y a aucun milieu de la société où on
peut insulter et humilier un enfant ça
n'existe pas et je pense qu'il y a une
grande éducation encore à faire du monde
entier hein des adultes des jeunes aussi
mais aussi des adultes de se dire que il
y a aucun lieu où on peut se permettre
de rabaisser un jeune et que en plus
c'est totalement contreproductif ça n'a
jamais aider personnees à être plus
performant
donc voilà moi il avait par exemple rasé
un élève dans dans le club house parce
que lui était chauve et donc il avait
rasé un élève de 14 ans et personne
n'avait rien dit enfin il était pas
coiffeur enfin je veux dire il y a peu
de lieux dans le monde il y en a eu par
le passé dans l'histoire des choses qui
se sont passées comme ça et aujourd'hui
on fait tout pour que ça ne se
reproduise plus jamais et là c'est
exactement la même chose on peut pas
permettre des choses comme ça il m'a
fait boire de l'alcool
enfin
c'est c'est finalement presque plus que
les violences sexuelles c'est ça qui d
enfin moi qui je pense qui m'a plus
détruit c'est le fait de m'avoir pendant
un moment flouté mes mes valeurs il me
faisait tricher sur le terrain et ça me
rendait folle et mon père voilà était
policier il avait un sens de la
justice très exacerbé et donc ça le
rendait fou et donc ça le mettait en
opposition avec lui et moi si je
trichais pas il m'abandonnait sur le
terrain il partait sa voiture et j'étais
au fin fond des Yvelines sur un parking
de nuit et il revenait une demi-heure
après et donc bah la fois d'après si la
balle elle était sur la ligne et qui me
regardait avec des mauvais yeux bah je
disais qu'elle était faute et ça me
bouffait tellement
intérieurement parce que j'ai mis des
années à me racheté euh auprès des
autres joueuses et euh et que ça m'a ça
a aussi participé au fait que j'étais
seule parce que du coup on il y a des
joueuses qui voulaient plus me parler
parce que j'avais pas un bon
comportement sur le cours et j'étais je
m'énervais beaucoup je pleurais beaucoup
sur le cours et tout ça ça a pas alerté
les fédération la Fédération et et les
les entraîneurs et les présidents alors
que ça fait partie des vous avez entendu
vous allez entendre plein de
psychologues voilà et ils vous diront
tous les symptômes c'est pas un symptôme
isolé qui fait qu'on peut dire qu'un
enfant est victime de violence sexuelle
mais plein mi bout tabout et me
concernant il y avait quand même plein
de signes je surinvestissais
l'école j'étais totalement esselé je
m'énervais très facilement sur un
terrain de tennis à pleurer sans arrêt
parce que c'était un lieu de souffrance
et aujourd'hui je joue plus au tennis
parce que j'arrive pas à jouer 1 heure
sans penser à ça et mon objectif c'est
de me dire que le jour où j'arriverai à
retourner sur un terrain de tennis et
passer 1 heure en mamusant sans y penser
j'aurais beaucoup avancé de ce côté-là
aujourd'hui je fais du padel en plus
c'est à la mode donc voilà et ça ça me
rappelle un peu le tennis mais comme
j'ai pas de mauvais souvenir sur ce
petit terrain en moquette avec des
vitres et ben j'y pense jamais et ça
paraît fou que juste un environnement me
permet de de pas y penser alors que
l'expertexpert psychiatre après les
procès a dit que j'étais reconnu 35 % en
[Musique]
en c'est pas invalidité mais en en
permanent de squel je lui ai demandé ça
veut dire quoi 35 % il me dit bah c'est
comme si 35 % de votre vie était dicté
par ce qui vous est arrivé et sur 24 he
ça fait 8h alors bon il y a l'heure où
on dort on va peut-être mais l'heure où
on dort en fait si j'en ai pas parlé
mais en fait oui je vous ai pas du tout
parlé de tous les traumatismes mais j'ai
eu beaucoup d'insomni beaucoup de
cauchemars encore aujourd'hui j'en fais
toutes les semaines ou toutes les nuits
j'ai de l'hyper vigilance ça veut dire
que la nuit je dors mais en fait je
pense que je dors sans dormir si mon
fils il fait il se retourne dans son lit
la chambre à côté je vais savoir qu'il
s'est retourné parce que je pense que je
suis dans une situation où il faut
toujours que je vois par où je pourrais
m'échapper enfin et j'avais des
problèmes avec la nourriture mais ça va
quand même mieux j'ai des problèmes avec
ma vie sexuelle voilà avant ça je
supportais pas la pénétration et j'avais
tendance à prendre aucune initiative
parce que j'ai peur de forcer l'autre à
faire quelque chose c'est problématique
parce que bah mes partenaires elles sont
consentantes mais je prends aucune
initiative aussi j'ai jamais eu de
relation sexuelle avec un homme alors je
sais j'en ai parlé avec le psychiatre on
sait pas si c'est enfin je ne sais pas
il ne sait pas si c'est parce que j'ai
été violé et que j'ai la peur des hommes
ou si juste j'aurais été homosexuel
selon lui non parce que avant ça j'avais
des petits copain je pense que très
certainement j'aurais été bisexuel parce
que je m'en fiche un peu j'aime une
personne mais j'ai j'ai peur jusqu'à
très récemment des hommes
d'ailleurs ça me fait pas peur de parler
devant vous tous mais par contre si je
me retrouve dans un ascenseur avec un
homme bah je serai pas très à l'aise
et voilà si quel quel autre traumatisme
j'ai je supporte pas l'abandon donc
jusqu'à récemment je pouvais pas rester
seu toute seule chez moi ou toute seule
avec mon fils il fallait toujours qu'il
y ait quelqu'un voilà depuis que je vais
voir le psychiatre ça va mieux
[Musique]
euh je rêve quand je rêve je rêve qui
qui me pour chasse et que j'arrive pas à
courir comme si j'étais dans un
escalator en marche arrière en marche
arrière et donc il finit par me
rattraper et au moment où il va pour me
rattraper soit je lui fais face et je le
tue soit je me dis mais elle est où ma
sœur elle a disparu et ça j'en ai pas
parlé mais en fait j'avais tellement
peur qu'il se passe ça avec ma petite
sœur qui était aussi entraîné par lui
qui avait 10
ans que
inconsciemment je me suis aussi
laisser être victime aussi longtemps
parce que je voulais pas qu'elle puisse
le
devenir et ça a été assez difficile
parce que j'aurais aimé à 27 ans qu'elle
qu'elle comprenne et ça a été trop dur
pour elle ça a été une trop grosse gifle
et elle a préféré
s'éloigner c'est pas du dénis mais se
dire elle elle m'a dit la semaine
dernière pour vous dire à quel point
c'est récent j'ai perdu ma sœur à 10 ans
et c'est dur parce que on avait une
belle relation on était complice cétait
vraiment une grande sœur qui l'emmenait
partout et en fait à 12 ans bah j'ai pu
parler à personne je suis restée
cloitrée dans ma chambre la dernière
chose que je devais faire le soir
c'était lui écrire un texto et la
première chose que je devais faire le
matin c'était de lui réécrire un texto
donc à quel point il y avait une
possession mentale j'avais pas un
centimètre d'espace de liberté et et ma
sœur en a beaucoup souffert parce
qu'elle a cru que je l'avais abandonné
je suis partie de chez moi à 16 ans
aussi parce que j'ai fui ce lieu où ça
s'était
passé c'est vrai j'ai voulu essayer de
d'avancer et elle en voulant la protéger
bah je l'ai abandonné en quelque sorte
et elle l'a très mal vécu et une fois on
était chez lui et il dit tu viens on va
chercher McDo et moi je veux pas y aller
parce que je sais ce qui va se passer et
du coup il me regarde et il dit Steve tu
viens avec moi en regardant ma petite
sœur après j'ai tellement eu peur avec
son regard que j'ai dit bah non j'y vais
je viens et ce jour-là il m'avait
demandé une fation et quelque part je me
suis sacrifié pour ma sœur
et c'est dur de me dire que aujourd'hui
elle a elle arrive pas
elle me dit qu'elle a une dette trop
énorme envers moi que elle peut pas
dépasser ça donc on narrive pas à avoir
de relation elle et moi alors que elle
est prof de PS comme moi elle fait du
tennis enfin on pourrait être tellement
proche et puis en fait ça nous a
totalement séparé
donc voilà et je suis partie vivre dans
le Sud-Ouest parce que j'arrivais plus à
vivre en île-de-fance il y avait trop de
gens que j'avais connu à ce moment-là il
y avit trop de lieux qui étaient les
lieux que je fréquentais et puis avant
que je dépose plainte j'ai continué à le
croiser régulièrement et même si lui a
toujours baissé les yeux après ça il a
toujours eu peur de moi alors qu'il a
pas eu peur des autres et ça c'est
encore une fois à la au cours d'assise
au cours des procès c'était le cas il
avait vraiment peur de moi et pas des
autres mais je pense que c'est l'âge qui
a il a son avocat a dit bon benah c'est
pas défendable on sait pas comment on va
défendre elle avait 12 ans elle
demandait pas ça c'était un petit garçon
avec une casquette à l'envers parce que
j'étais pas du tout du tout féminine je
suis pas beaucoup beaucoup plus mais
mais du coup
voilà j'ai aujourd'hui je lu en veux
plus c'est déjà un énorme norme pas et
euh j'espère juste que toutes les années
qui va passer en prison parce que j'ai
conscience aussi que 18 ans c'est une
énorme peine et j'ai conscience de la
chance qu'on a eu d'avoir une justice
comme ça et que c'est vraiment rare
c'est pas souvent le cas il y a très peu
de victimes mineures qui qui arrivent à
à à se faire reconnaître victime et donc
on a eu cette chance et j'espère que
tout ce temps lui permettra de de
prendre conscience de ce qu'il a fait et
moi j'ai toujours cette peur parce que
au moment juste avant le verdict il a
dit de toute façon je sais que je vais
retourner en prison et pour longtemps et
quand je sortirai je partir en Australie
et j'irai entraîner et je me dis bon bah
là euh à ce moment-là il avait pas
encore du tout assez de
recul entre 2014 et 2020 donc
voilà après ce témoignage d'une avec une
telle sincérité je vais euh moi j'ai pas
de question sur le témoignage je vais
laisser la parole à à Madame la rapporte
alors merci vraiment beaucoup pour le
courage de ce témoignage m'associe
complètement à madame la Présidente euh
pour vraiment le courage de vous faire
preuve aujourd'hui et j'imagine ce que
ça pu être aussi au moment du du procès
alors comme vous le savez le la création
de cette commission d'enquête était
aussi dans le but de déterminer en fait
les dfonctionnements ou les défaillances
au sein des fédérations notamment en ce
qui concerne les VSS mais d'autres aussi
faits de violence comme vous avez pu
d'ailleurs témoigner aujourd'hui que ce
soit par la parole les violences
physiques ou discrimination ou autre et
et c'est vrai qu'on retrouve chez
plusieurs victimes un schéma assez
similaire c'està-dire déjà l'isolement
avec l'entraîneur le fait qu'il y ait
vraiment une
relation très poussé entre l'entraîneur
finalement et et les jeunes qu'on
entraîne cette responsabilité très jeune
finalement des jeunes sportifs cette
responsabilité vis-àvis de la famille
vis-à-vis de la performance sportive
vis-à-vis de son entraîneur de son club
et tout ça on le retrouve c'est vrai Mo
en tout cas depuis que on a lancé la
commission d'enquête et tous les
témoignages qu'on a eu on retrouve ce
schéma et malheureusement j'ai pas le
sentiment en tout cas même si les la
parole s'est libérée et qu'on a le
sentiment que l' Mertin a était un peu
levé on a quand même le sentiment que ça
perdure au sein de de ces fédérations et
de et de ces clubs et et d'ailleurs
plusieurs personnes nous ont rapporté le
fait qu'elles avaient peur de témoigner
ou de parler puisqu'elle risquait d'être
mise à l'écart sanctionné ne plus
pouvoir participer à des compétitions
quel que soit que ce soit sportif
dirigeant entraîneur ou tout
l'écosystème finalement autour de autour
de ces de ces fédérations moi j'ai une
question vraiment sur la Fédération
Française de Tennis qui s'est constitué
partie civile au moment du procès donc
contre votre ancien entraînemur et le
premier dysfonctionnement concerne
d'abord votre ancien club où réé lomerta
vous l'avez dit à demi-mot mais alors
que beaucoup de personnes semblaient
avoir des soupçons en tout cas
semblaient savoir qu'il avait un
comportement inapproprié et
les bonnes performances du club semblent
avoir poussé certains à fermer les yeux
est-ce que vous nous le confirmez
aujourd'hui ah
ouais oui c'est c'est
vrai apparemment il y a une une une
seule dame au cours du procès ça a été
ça a été dit par
l'enquêtrice qui avait été voir le
président du club en disant qu'il avait
un comportement inapproprié envers les
jeunes avec violence verbale physique et
un comportement ambigu avec avec
certaines joueuses et euh et le
président lui avait répondu oui mais il
nous ramène des titres et ça ça fait
écho à une phrase de Madame oua casterra
pendant le colloque où elle a dit aucune
médaille ne vaut un sacrifice tel et
c'est vrai que de une c'était faux parce
que en fait il entraînaient les
meilleurs joueurs donc forcément ils
avaient des titres je veux dire c'était
pas un bon entraîneur en plus si c'estd
que parfois il y des très bons
entraîneurs qui sont aussi des des des
des pédocriminels mais euh là en
l'occurrence c'était même pas un bon
entraîneur en revanche c'est un
entraîneur qui consacrait énormément de
temps et ça dans la vie d'un sportif ben
c'est sûr que ça demande un tel
engagement pour les familles comme vous
l'avez dit tant euh en terme de temps
qu'en terme financier que un entraîneur
qui qui est disponible le soir les
weekends qui compte pas ses heures qui
fait des entraînements entre guillemets
gratuitement et cetera bah forcément euh
ça va aider à avoir des résultats mais
euh mais c'était pas un bon entraîneur
et oui les les gens disaient que c'était
sa méthode que c'était comme ça qu'il
était dur mais que il poussait les gens
à faire du mieux possible enfin c'est on
peut on peut aider les jeunes à tirer le
meilleur Dee même sans pour autant les
forcer à faire des choses qu' sont pas
prêts à accepter et la frontière est
parfois pas facile mais c'est tout c'est
tout l'enjeu d'un et c'est pour ça aussi
que les éducateurs et en entraîneurs
doivent être formés et aujourd'hui voilà
il y a des au sein de leur formation ils
ont des des UE sur ça qui était pas pas
trop le cas avant alors que ça paraît
être quand même la base avant d'être un
entraîneur de tennis on est un éducateur
et donc on doit savoir quelles sont les
valeurs quelle est la psychologie de
l'enfant quelles sont les méthodes de
enfin moi ça c'est ça me paraît plus
essentiel que de savoir techniquement
comment on fait un coup droit parce que
quand on laisse un enfant aller dans un
club de tennis ou autre la première des
choses c'est c'est qu'on doit garantir
son intégrité physique et morale et
comme l'école et à partir du moment où
on laisse son enfant un endroit où il
peut lui arriver quelque chose moi je
préfère que mon enfant il reste nul au
tennis et qu'il lui arrive jamais
rien donc donc ça c'est la première
chose après la Fédération française de
tennis comme c'est celle que je connais
le mieux je vais en parler elle depuis
notre affaire effectivement elle fait
beaucoup dans ce domaine làà avec notre
association rebond effectivement on est
partenaire on fait des sensibilisation
auprès de toutes les ligues aux
présidents des ligues au comités des
ligues aux entraîneurs aux équipes
techniques régionales et cetera et aussi
au sein des tournois jeunes nationaux où
je fais une sensibilisation aux jeunes
sur sur qu'est-ce qui est interdit
qu'est-ce qu' autorisé qu'est-ce qu' une
relation
saine excusez-moi je voudrais juste vous
interrompre sur ce sujet parce que donc
en collaboration avec d'anciennes
victimes de votre bourreau vous avez
cette association rebond qui œuvre
prévenir en tout cas toutes les
violences tout types de violence auprès
de mineurs c'est bien cela donc je
voulais savoir où était domicilié votre
association comment elle s'organisait
comment elle s'animait sur le terrain
votre association j'imagine que vous
avez des bénévoles mais vous avez aussi
des salariés peut-être alors non on n
pas assez de subvention justement pour
avoir des salariés voà donc c'est
intéressant que vous puissiez en tout
cas vous êtes là aussi pour nous
présenter votre
association et je vous remercie de nous
en parler pour nous puissions la
connaître davantage alors donc c'est un
petit peu comme colosse au pied d'argile
sauf que eux ils ont ils ont bien
progressé nous on est encore au début
par rapport à par rapport à eux mais
l'objectif est le même effectivement il
y a un volet prévention et
sensibilisation auprès des différents
publics que ce soit dirigeants
entraîneurs parents et
enfants et ensuite dans tous les strates
de la Fédération donc ça va de du CNE
donc du Centre national d'entraînement
jusqu'au tout petit club d'une campagne
et et ensuite on fait aussi de l'aide et
soutien aux victimes donc on a plusieurs
victimes dont certaines ont été pas mal
médiatisé l'an dernier qui sont dans
l'association et qu'on a aidé dans ce
chemin qui est justement la procédure
quand on se lance dans une procédure on
n' pas du tout idée de ce que ça va
représenter sur différents plans sur le
moi je pensais pas que ça serait
médiatisé au début j'étais pas du tout
prête à ça
euh ensuite je venais d'acheter un
appartement et et je pensais pas que ça
allait me coûter 600 € par mois de frais
d'avocat et heureusement que la
Fédération française de tennis a été là
pour nous faire des subvention et nous
aider à régler nos frais d'avocat parce
que voilà j'en ai pour 60000 € de frais
d'avocat et bah je gagnais 1800 € par
mois en étant prof et ça allait être
très compliqué donc heureusement qu'ils
nous ont
aidé et je sais que c'est pas toujours
local tout les fédérations sont pas
toujours parti civil et nous c'était la
première fois que la Fédération
Française de Tennis l'était et pour
parler avec la déléguée juridique de la
Fédération très régulièrement puisque
c'est avec elle que je que j'interviens
sur les différentes actions je lui ai
dit il faut pas qu'il y ait une machine
arrière et il faut que maintenant ça
soit systématique que la Fédération soit
toujours partie civile mais ça leur
coûte aussi beaucoup d'argent parce que
ça leur demande aussi un avocat donc la
la Fédération française de tennis a
décidé de faire appel à un assureur et
en fait il y a 2 € de plus dans la
licence je suis pas sûre du chiffre je
crois en tout cas il y a une part de la
licence qui a légèrement augmenté pour
pouvoir justement aider les victimes qui
déposent plainte à payer leurs frais
d'avocat c'est l'assurance qui prend en
charge alors évidemment il y a des
critères puisque c'est une assurance
c'est pas ils sont pas philanthropiques
donc il faut que ça soit dans les 5 ans
alors on sait que les personnes parlent
généralement beaucoup plus tard que ça
mais bon c'est déjà mieux que rien et il
faut que la personne a été licencier au
moment des faits et le soit toujours au
moment du dépôt de plainte et voilà il
couvre 20000 € de frais d'avocat
l'assurance donc c'est déjà une super
belle avancée qui a fait la fédération
en espérant que il puisse étendre ça à
10 ans et un peu plus parce qu'on voit
que cimfar et ben elle a 46 ans et elle
a parlé 7ette semaine donc
voilà en fait je ça m'a ça me fait
penser aussi à autre chose alors le
délai de prescription a été rallongé et
ça c'est vraiment une c'est vraiment
quelque chose de d'essentiel à mon sens
et dans certains pays il y a pas de
description pour les les crimes de
violence sexuelle sur
mineur c'est le cas au Luxembourg c'est
le cas au Danemark au Pays-Bas en Suisse
et en fait les répercussions elles sont
sur toute une vie et c'est parfois ça
nous arrive quand on a 10 ans et puis on
en on a oublié il y a des amnésies
traumatiques ça existe des gens qui
oublient pendant 30 40 ans et puis tout
d'un coup ils se souviennent et il y a
des gens qui sont dans le déni qui se
disent non c'était pas du viol et puis
il y a des gens qui disent je sais que
c'était du viol mais je préfère pas en
parler parce que il y a trop d'enjeux et
donc la prise de parole elle est elle
est elle est
forcément sur un délai qui qui à mon
avis est bien au-delà de encore la
prescription aujourd'hui et je pense que
que c'est un crime voilà aujourd'hui en
France il y a que le crime contre
l'humanité il me semble qui n'a pas de
de prescription et je voilà je pense que
ça serait ça serait quand même un beau
message envoyé aux victimes et en même
temps une épée de Damocles ou qui ne
tombera jamais pour les pour les les
coupables parce que nous finalement il
il y a eu des prescriptions dans notre
cas et euh si elle VAD elle c'était pas
arrivé qu jours avant benah il y aurait
eu prescription pour elle et peut-être
qu'aucune de nous aurait parlé et puis
ça ce serait jamais su donc voilà pour
moi c'est c'est c'est important c'est
une chose que que je trouve importante
après il y a autre chose aussi je me dis
pour le après
alors j'ai conscience que à partir du
moment où une personne a purgé sa peine
elle retrouve sa liberté c'est c'est
tout le c'est tout l'enjeu de la justice
mais il y a des pays encore une fois
comme l'Australie qui sur le passeport
c'est écrit quand c'est des des
prédateurs criminels sur enfant et et le
pays qui les reçoit est en estant droit
de les refuser et ils peuvent même il y
a même des des des personnes en
Australie qui ne peuvent pas quitter le
territoire pour protéger non pas juste
les enfants de leur pays mais les
enfants du monde entier je sais que ça
pose question moi-même je me pose la
question je ne dis pas que je voudrais
que que ça le soit mais je me pose ça me
pose question de me dire est-ce que ça
serait pas
aussi
garantir une protection supplémentaire
pour les les les enfants de tout pays
sachant que voilà c'est d'ailleurs
c'était à l'Assemblée nationale que ça
avait été sur d'une commission où le
chiffre était sorti 37 % des prédateurs
sexuel sur mineur recommettre une
infraction après avoir purgé une peine
c'est quand même beaucoup et c'est 37 %
où les gens ont reparlé mais pour
combien combien de personnes n'ont pas
parlé je pense que rien que nous ns
concernant on était quatre partis
civiles mais en fait je pense qu'on
était plus de 20
victimes de rien que sur les les
personnes qui ont témoigné qui à la fin
disent mais je ne souhaite pas porter
plainte alors que ça relevait du viol il
y en avait déjà quatre ou cinq certaines
où il y avait prescription certaines qui
s'étaient enfu d'autres qui n'ont pas
été retrou prouver
euh voilà c'est c'est on a rendu justice
aussi pour toutes les autres mais
concernant pour revenir à l'association
parce que je pars un peu pour revenir à
l'association donc on a surtout comme
partenaire là pour l'instant la
Fédération Française de Tennis
j'aimerais obtenir l' agrément de
l'éducation nationale pour pouvoir aller
dans les collèges lycées aussi pour
faire des sensibilisations comme le fait
colos d'ailleurs pour l'instant on le
fait mais on comme on n pas l'agrément
c'est pas quelque chose d'automatique
qui peut être demandé dans un parcours
de de formation et euh et
ensuite ah vous avez une question
allez-y non non non non allez-y
allez-y désolé je voulais pas vous
interrompre mais en fait c'est en en
écoutant et en repensant à la question
que je vous ai posé tout à l'heure
lorsque vous m'avez dit que
effectivement ça avait été signalé
auprès du président du club est-ce que
ce président a été inquiété par la
justice du fait d'avoir su des choses de
ne pas être intervenu de ne pas avoir
fait de signalement peut-être plus haut
au niveau supérieur donc est-ce que il y
a eu des plaintes ou quelque chose qui a
été fait de ce point de vue-là alors il
est décédé avant notre dépôt de plainte
donc on ne saura jamais plusieurs
personnes ont été très très mal à l'aise
lorsqu'ils ont été appelés à la barre
parce que ils avaient eu un comportement
où justement on leur a on leur a dit
mais vous saviez dit des choses vous
n'avez rien dit il y a notamment une qui
était prof de PS et qui par exemple
avait 27 ans à ce moment-là et on était
parti en
tournoi par équipe et c'était pas avec
moi c'était avec les les prochaines donc
Astrid et Mathilde et il avait demandé à
dormir avec Astrid dans la chambre et
que Mathilde dorme avec un autre
accompagnant adulte de 45 ans et il y
avait donc cet adulte de 45 ans
l'entraîneur enfin la femme de 27 ans
qui était prof de PS plus d'autres
adultes de l'équipe et personne n'a rien
dit et euh bah il y a personne d'autre
n'a été inquiété par la loi dans notre
affaire mais il y a quand même eu
beaucoup de manquement et c'est on a
quand même permis à des jeunes de 14 15
ans de dormir avec l'entraîneur parce
que l'entraîneur l'avait demandé enfin
moi aujourd'hui ça m'arrive je seraiis
dans une équipe où il y a un entraîneur
qui demande à dormir avec un mineur ça
ça serait pas possible donc je trouve ça
fou qu'à l'époque mais encore une fois
parce qu'il avait une telle emprise pas
seulement sur nous mais sur le club
entier que les gens avaient peur de lui
en fait parce que c'était quelqu'un de
violent quelqu'un qui avait assis une
autor il était omnipotent dans ce club
il faisait la pluie et le BE temp il
décidait de tout on lui laissait tout
passer et c'est sûr que c'était un
terrain favorable pour nous à ces
violences je voudrais revenir aussi sur
sur ces signalements euh plus de 60 %
des signalements sur le dispositif
signal sport du ministère concerne des
éducateurs des sportifs et des bénévoles
ou des
professionnels ce matin nous étions en
audition avec Madame mirriam Salmi
psychologue du sport que nous avons
auditionné elle a souligné donc la
nécessité de ne pas laisser des mineurs
seuls avec leurs entraîneurs ceci étant
particulièrement vulnérable vous l'avez
dit également hein du fait de leur âge
de la relation particulière qu'ils
entretiennent avec lui une véritableise
de prise de conscience émergé au sein de
la Fédération française de tennis ou
a-t-elle émergé au sein de la Fédération
française de tennis à votre connaissance
est-ce que des éducateurs et entraîneurs
sont davantage contrôlés et selon vous
le respect de l'honorabilité des
éducateurs sportifs fonctionnent-il bien
suffisamment alors alors à l'époque par
exemple la carte professionnelle c'était
quelque chose qui n'était jamais affiché
dans les clubs à mon époque quand
j'étais jeune et même on demandait pas
vraiment même les diplômes c'estàdire
que
un un entraîneur changeait de club et on
lui demandait pas les diplômes ni quoi
que ce soit donc en fait par exemple
nous il avait il avait menti il avait
dit qu'il avait le be2 alors qu'il avait
juste le BE1 alors il pouvait entraîner
ça ne change pas le fait qu'il était
quand même entraîneur mais le be2 permet
d'accéder à des postes qui n'aurait pas
dû avoir voilà de dirigeants de
directeurs sportifs dans des gros clubs
et
aujourd'hui la Fédération Française de
Tennis fait beaucoup plus de de contrôle
sur ça d'ailleurs j'ai reçu moi-même un
mail pour dire qu'il fallait que j'ai ma
carte professionnelle à jour euh donc
oui maintenant il y a beaucoup plus de
de contrôle il demande à ce que ça soit
affiché que ça soit contrôlé et euh et
il y a beaucoup plus de passerelles
faites aussi dès que il y a des
remontées qui qui sont faites entre le
ministère de la Justice et le ministère
de des sports il y a il y a une
collaboration qui est faite qui n'était
pas le cas à l'époque donc ça c'est ça
c'est vraiment une très bonne chose
après euh pour des questions financières
même si c'est demandé maintenant que un
entraîneur ne dorme pas avec son joueur
ou sa joueuse quand il part en
déplacement alors évidemment il y a des
sports qui sont plus ou moins touchés
par ce phénomène au tennis c'est un
sport où on part beaucoup en tournoi
donc on est beaucoup en déplacement avec
les entraîneurs effectivement ça
représente un coup parce que ça veut
dire prendre deux chambres au lieu d'une
mais maintenant c'est ce qui est demandé
alors dans les faits je ne sais pas si
c'est toujours respecté mais avant ce n
était même pas demandé comme ça voilà
ensuite moi souvent j'en parle avec la
Fédération française de tennis pour
l'instant je trouve qu'il y en a encore
pas assez mais moi j'aimerais qu'il y
ait plus d'entraîneurs femmes pas parce
que les femmes ne peuvent pas être des
prédatrices sexuelles hein c'est c'est
déjà arrivé mais bon il y a quand même
selon les résultat de la CIVIS enfin
dans le il y a 98 % des des des
prédateurs qui sont des hommes et euh et
ensuite parce que je trouve que de toute
façon c'est bien d'avoir deux
entraîneurs et je préférerais que on
mette en place des des pôles
d'entraînement avec deux entraîneurs et
quatre joueurs plutôt que un entraîneur
avec un joueur même au-delà de de des
entre guillemets dérapag c'est pas des
dérapages mais ouais on va dire ça qui
pu qui pourrait y arriver c'est c'est
surtout que c'est aussi de toute façon
une personne n'a pas bon partout je dire
même un très bon entraîneur il peut pas
tout apporter et moi je sais que en EPS
j'aime bien travailler avec ma collègue
qui pourtant est très différente de moi
mais parce que je pense P qu'elle
apporte d'autres choses aussi à mes
élèves et d'avoir deux cadres deux
façons de penser d'avoir des valeurs
communes mais qui peuvent quand même
voilà être un petit peu différente et
ben je pense que ça enrichit dans tous
les cas les enfants et les jeunes donc
je moi je serais plutôt favorable à ce
que il y ait plus d'entraîneurs pour un
petit groupe et qu'on puisse avoir aussi
une émulation entre jeunes de leur âge
qui puissent être avec des pères parce
que quand on a 12 ans et que tout d'un
coup on fréquente plus jamais des
enfants de 12 ans bah dans sa
construction c'est quand même
problématique aussi parce que avant
d'être un joueur de tennis ou un joueur
de foot ou peu importe on reste un jeune
et donc c'est plus important de se
construire comme ça que de se construire
uniquement par rapport à son sport déjà
parce qu'on n'est pas sûr d'être sportif
de haut niveau et ensuite même si on le
devient il y a un après et et on sait
aussi le nombre de dépression qu'il y a
chez les sportifs de niveau qui arrêent
donc parce que tout d'un coup en fait
ils ont l'impression de perdre leur vie
parce que c'était leur unique repère et
je pense queil faut essayer de garder le
plus longtemps possible des
repères un peu plus classiques dans le
sens où s'ils peuvent rester à l'école
c'est mieux s'ils peuvent rester dans
leur famille c'est mieux et alors tout
le monde n'est pas d'accord avec moi
même au sein de la Fédération française
de tennis mais moi je préfère que les
enfants reste s'entraîner proche de chez
eux le plus longtemps possible et pas
qu'il partent à 12 ans en pôle- France à
Poitier voilà je préfère qu'il rest
jusqu'à 16 ans entraîner dans leur
région et contrôle de
contrôle de l'honorabilité des
éducateurs bah ça je sais je sais pas si
ils ont alors il y a un référent dans
chaque ils sont en train de mettre en
place un référent dans chaque comité à
la Fédération Française de Tennis donc
qui serait en quelque sorte la personne
ressources à aller voir si il y a une
suspicion mais pour l'instant c'est pas
encore totalement mis en place et
surtout ils ont pas été tous formés et
il faudrait que ça soit le cas dans
chaque club ce qui pour l'instant n'est
pas le cas il faudrait que dans chaque
club à mon sens il y a une personne qui
soit formée et sensibilisée à ça et qui
soit connu et reconnu de l'ensemble du
club des adhérents que ce soit aussi
bien les parents les jeunes et les
éducateurs comme étant la personne qui
va faire remonter à Signal sport qui va
être en lien avec différentes
associations et ça pour l'instant c'est
pas le cas et donc je ne sais pas en
terme de contrôle
d'honorabilité exactement où elle en est
si ce n'est que je sais que maintenant
il c'est c'est plus systématique qu'il a
un contrôle des cartes
professionnelles mais par exemple c'est
disait que je j'avais posé la question
si un entraîneur de l'étranger vient
est-ce qu'on sait s'il a été condamné
dans son pays j'avais demandé à Fabien
Bourdet qui m'a dit c'est très c'est
très difficile à savoir parce que déjà
déjà au niveau français c'est difficile
de de faire les les liens entre les
fichiers ceux qui sont fichés et et euh
et sil Contin continuent à à enseigner
et ensuite s'il viennent d'autres pays
il y a des pays qui apparemment ne
donnent pas d'information ou d'autres
qui sont encore plus en retard et qui
ont pas du tout fait ce travail là donc
il y a parce que les entraîneurs bougent
beaucoup aussi on a beaucoup
d'entraîneurs canadien belge suisse
luxembourgeois enfin c'est c'est le
monde du sport c'est un monde où on on
bouge assez facilement donc c'est vrai
que si la personne elle part d'un pays
pour aller refaire ça ailleurs et queon
a pas de trace ça POS aussi
problème une question de notre collèue
notre collègue Jérôme Gedge s'il vous
plaît madame coui il faut
éteindre voilà bah évidemment merci je
évidemment pas revenir sur l'intensité
de votre témoignage même si de fait il
appellerait aussi beaucoup de questions
sur la manière dont vous décidez de
prendre la parole enfin ce qui est
toujours au-delà du milieu sportif le
cas de n'importe quel abus sexuel sur un
mineur de se poser la question à quel
moment on est capable de prendre la
parole et mais ça fait le lien aussi
avec la question que je veux vous poser
qui porte sur l'action de rebond vous
nous dites on fait de la sensibilisation
de la prévention et de l'information et
donc aujourd'hui moi ce qui m'intéresse
je pense qui nous intéresse c'est de
comprendre ce des messages que vous
arrivez à à faire passer je prends une
seule question précise est-ce que
aujourd'hui dans vos sensibilisations
dans vos formations et plus largement
dans les messages que la FFT fait passer
par exemple cette règle de dire un
adulte ne peut pas être seul avec un
jeune est un message qui est clair qui
est assumé qui est porté qui est
revendiqué en disant il peut pas y avoir
euh voilà euh même question sur euh et
ça a fait le lien avec mon premier point
sur l'aide à la libération de la parole
c'està ce qu'il est dit aujourd'hui dans
ces écoles de tennis dans les clubs
euh ça peut arriver avec vos entraîneurs
ça peut arriver avec les bénévoles et
donc vous devez signaler vous devez le
dire c'est normal de le dire il y a
aucune raison est-ce que je quels sont
les supports au-delà des formations que
vous faites pour un peu le systématiser
pour que dans le milieu du sport se
disent ce qui se dit dans d'autres
milieux euh au contact avec des enfants
de pouvoir dire s'il se passe quelque
chose dites-le euh voilà c'est quoi les
supports est-ce que dans le livret dans
le avec la licence est-ce que dans la
newsletter est-ce que aujourd'hui our'hi
ces messages sont assumés et qu'il a pas
le côté de se dire on en parle pas parce
que on veut pas montrer que il y a des
choses qui vont pas quoi voilà alors il
y a une il y a un outil de formation en
ligne qui s'appelle lift à la Fédération
française de tennis et dans cette
formation il y a des il y a une unité
sur les violences sexuelles où là
justement il y a differs divers points
justement comme vous disiez sur ne pas
se retrouver seul dans dans un dans une
voiture avec un jeune éviter les
allers-retours seul et cetera euh mais
euh il y a il y a pas encore assez de
connaissance à tous les étages on va
dans n'importe quel club de France c'est
pas systématique pour les gens que ça
puisse poser problème qu'on puisse être
seul par exemple un terrain les tennis
couvert souvent ça c'est des bulles et
donc si les parents ne viennent pas sur
le terrain personne le voit donc donc
c'est des milieux où on est facilement
esselé et bah je mais ça demande
tellement de alors ça demande ça demande
beaucoup de de budget mais c'est c'est
aussi à long terme penser sur les
infrastructures de les rendre aussi plus
visible même si on sait que c'est c'est
pas c'est c'est pas uniquement pendant
les lieux d'entraînement où les les
violences vont avoir lieu hein il y a
tellement d'autres possibilités mais
mais j'ai l'impression que les gens
encore voient le milieu sportif un peu
comme un milieu différent où on pourrait
se permettre d'autre chose parce qu'il y
a une performance attendue alors que il
y a aussi dans le milieu de la musique
de la performance attendue mais ce côté
dépassement physique et finalement
violence physique qu'on qu'on accepte
bah permet
d'avoir des des comportements qui
arrivent plus souvent peut-être que dans
d'autres milieux et et il y a encore
beaucoup beaucoup de travail je pense
dans les fédérations pour que tout le
monde des bénévoles aux parents prennent
conscience que on ne parle pas mal à un
enfant dans le milieu sportif comme on
ne parle pas mal de d'un enfant à
l'école ça ça passerait pas qu'on dise à
un enfant souvent je dans les formations
justement je fais le parallèle et je
leur dis mais si on vous on dit à votre
enfant oh il est nul tu avances pas tu
cours à de à l'heure les parents
cautionnent quelque part pas tous mais
beaucoup vont cautionner ça alors que je
leur dis mais s'il est en mat on dit
mais vraiment tu réfléchis à de à
l'heure mais tu sis pas additionné tu es
vraiment un ASZ alors là les parents
vont soffusquer alors que finalement
c'est exactement la même chose pour
l'enfant et euh il faut il faut que ça
ça ça change la mentalité alors c'est à
force de je pense d'exemples de
de je pense que les témoignages c'est
c'est important parce que c'est là aussi
les gens prennent conscience que ça peut
arriver à tout le monde parce que nos
histoires par exemple on éétait pas des
famill amille complètement abandonné
avec des enfants qui qui étaient seuls
on dit ah oui mais moi ça pourrait pas
m'arriver enfin souvent on entend et
c'est terrible c'est que personne n'est
à l'abri aucun milieu
socio-pressionnel aucun âge et aucun
sexe n'est à l'abri donc il faut
vraiment que ça soit moi j'ai à chaque
fois que je prends une classe en cours
je me dis j'ai au moins trois élèves qui
ont vécu des violences sexuel et c'est
quand même avoir conscience de ça quand
on accueille une classe toutes les 2
heures c'est quand même et en fait très
peu c'est c'est c'est pas su parce que
les enfants n'en ont pas encore parlé
mais c'est les chiffres et c'est quand
même c'est pas quelque chose qui arrive
une fois tous les 10000 et c'est ce qui
serait déjà trop mais là on parle quand
même de enfin c'est c'est énorme les
chiffres là ils disent Amélie ou Cera
rappelait que c'était un enfant sur 7
qui qui qui va avoir des violences
sexuelles au milieu dans le milieu
sportif avant la majorité un enfant sur
se
c'est un enfant par groupe on fait un
groupe de tennis il y en a un qui avant
ses 18 ans va subir des violences
sexuelles dans le dans le milieu
sportif Claudia une question
oui alors moi je vous remercie également
pour votre témoignage que même nous on a
du mal à à
entendre non alors vous êtes
enseignante y a-t-il pas une passerelle
possible justement pour
comme une forme
d'instruction pour protéger des enfants
entre l'éducation nationale notamment
par les profs de sport sur justement de
de de de dire à des enfants et ben vous
devez pas accepter qu'on vous insulte
enfin on le fait avec nos propres
enfants petits enfant mais au-delà de ça
on sait qu'il y a des familles qui sont
pas forcément au faites c'est vrai que
dire la nulité ça ne se dit pas un
enfant parce qu'un jour il dira je suis
nul alors qu'il est pas forcément nul il
est moins bon qu'un autre ou il a
d'autres qualités enfin je veux dire on
peut toujours être positif ça c'est
première ma première question et la
deuxième ça concerne alors quand on est
enseignant on est obligé de regarder sur
le fichier des prédateurs pour être
recruté alors je le sais parce que je
suis conseillère régional tout le
personnel qui travaille dans les lycées
on n'est pas soumis à ça donc une
personne peut avoir violé et travailler
au contact d'enfants ce qui est une
vraie problématique et à mon avis en
tant que législateur faudra peut-être un
jour qu'on se penche là-dessus donc
quand un entraîneur ou a un jour agressé
est-ce qu'il y a la possibilité
d'enquêter quand on le recrute dans un
une
fédération alors justement ça ça me fait
penser à au moment où il il y avait
l'instruction il avaient dit qu'il
fallait plus qu'il ait un travail en
contact de jeunes dans le milieu
éducatif et et pour pouvoir sortir de
préventive il avait dit j'ai trouvé un
emploi dans une
auto-école et j'avais dit bah moi ça me
pose problème parce que ça veut dire
qu'il va avoir des mineurs et et donc
mais comme ça ça avait pas paru choqué
et ça veut bien dire qu'il y a quand
même encore comme si on devait
cloisonner enfin il y a y a le milieu
sportif mais il y a tellement de milieux
où il y a des jeunes qu'effectivement ça
peut être ça peut être au milieu
scolaire dans dans des Ulisses en milieu
hospitalier enfin on peut être en
contact des jeunes par plein de BIS
différents donc effectivement je pense
que il il y aurait besoin de légiférer
sur ça et et ensite justement votre
question sur les passerelles c'est ce
que j'aimerais présenter à à Monsieur
hatal et Madame oua ctera donc là c'est
la rentrée en plus aujourd'hui ils sont
ensemble justement à H thèse pour parler
de PS donc c'est drôle et et donc
j'aimerais les les voir pour leur
proposer des actions parce que
j'aimerais j'aimerais si si on pouvait
mettre cette action en place de former
tous les enseignants de PS à travers les
les réunions du NSS qu'on a chaque début
d'année qui est une formation de fait
pour que les enseignants de PS au sein
de leur établissement ensuite puissent
faire cette formation auprès de leurs
élèves tout d'abord du qui sont présents
en UNSS parce que c'est quand même la
plus grosse fédération hein on parle de
fédération sportive mais l'UNSS c'est
quand même la plus grosse
FD et ensuite et ensuite les tendre à
tous les enseignants et à tous les
personnels et effectivement vous avez
raison quand on engage un personnel de
cantine ou un agent d'entretien ou autre
euh effectivement c'est des personnes
qui évoluent avec des des jeunes tous
les jours et donc moi je m'arrête pas
seulement à la communauté éducative je
pense qu'il faut former tous les
personnels au sens large euh et
d'ailleurs même si c'est pas juste parce
qu'ils sont en contact avec des jeunes
c'est aussi parce qu'ils sont parents
onces grands-parents et que c'est une
parole qui doit être diffusée sur toute
la société parce que comme vous l'avez
dit nous on en parle à nos enfants et
petits-enfants mais c'est pas toujours
le cas et il y a beaucoup de milieux où
on on parle pas du tout de ces choses-là
euh bon alors évidemment là n notre
sujet c'est les fédérations on sait
aussi que le premier lieu c'est la
famille euh mais euh pour les les les
violences sexuelles mais euh l'école
sert aussi à ça et je pense qu'il
faudrait faire plus de passerelles il
faudrait qu'il y ait des formateurs et
moi d'ailleurs je je quand si je j'ai
l'occasion de les voir prochainement je
me proposeraai j'aimerais bien
aujourd'hui je suis professeur de PS
dans un collège mais si on me demandait
si je voulais faire une autre mission au
sein de l'éducation nationale par
rapport à ça je dirais oui vraiment euh
euh avec en train j'aimerais bien euh
qu'il y ait des référents dans chaque
établissement un référent qui est formé
et qui est là pour relayer un petit peu
comme on a fait là avec le programme
PHARE avec les pour le harcèlement bah
au sens large aussi sur les violences
sexuelles et les violences tout courts
euh parce que ça peut être des violences
physiques ça peut être on en a voilà
parlé des violence verbale et euh et ça
a été par exemple le cas dans mon
collège où j'ai des élèves j'étais prof
principale de 4e l'an dernier sont venus
me voir en me disant madame on va
arrêter la section foot parce que non
pas parce que on va arrêter la section
foot donc j'avais plein de garçons je
leur dis ah bon mais pourquoi et moi ça
m'étonnait il venaent à mes créneaux du
NSS le midi au foot je les vois jouer
sur les terrains j'habite la ville où
j'enseigne je les vois jouer toute la
journée sur les terrains de foot quand
il y a pas école ils font les tournois
ils font les matchs il parce que il nous
parle mal l'entraîneur et l'entraîneur
c'est l'entraîneur du club et c'est pas
le prof de PS qui fait les cours à la
section sportive et euh et donc là euh
ils me disent qu'ils nous disent ouais
vous êtes des petites vous
allez vous prendre une branlée ce
weekend enfin voilà sans arrêt des des
remarques comme ça donc des
remarques homophobes des remarques
sexistes des insultes et donc ils m'ont
dit qu'ils voulaient arrêter et donc il
mon chef d'établissement l'an dernier
quand même quand je lui en parle ils me
font oh tu es sûr ça m'étonne parce que
quand même c'est quelqu'un de
bien bon alors je sa peut-être mon passé
qui me si sil dit ce genre de chose
c'est pas quelqu'un de bien et et
ensuite pourquoi des enfants viendrait
me raconter ça enfin c'estd que c'est
tellement difficile pour parler quand on
est jeune que si en plus les rarfis où
ils arrivent à prendre la parole on leur
dit non mais c'est pas possible
l'entraîneur c'est quelqu'un de
bien on peut pas s'en sortir donc donc
voilà j'ai demandé que on puisse faire
une réunion avec le fameux ent qui a qui
a changé de club donc c'est lui qui a
quitté le club mais il est entraîneur
dans la ville d'à côté hein donc donc ça
ne change strictement rien si ce n'est
que mes élèves de
4e voilà maintenant ils vivent leur
section sportive plus sereinement mais
enin il faut vraiment que on et quand
j'en ai parlé en salle des profs on se
dit quand même les profs ils ont fait un
master ils réfléchissent un peu bah ils
m'ont dit oh mais c'est comme ça c'est
le
sport et alors c'était une Preve de
français et je lui ai dit mais oui mais
toi je t'entends hyper souvent dans ta
salle tu as fait cinq fautes en français
mais tu es vraiment une brêle oh là là
mais et elle me regarde comme ça je dis
bah c'est exactement la même chose et
elle me dit ah bah ouais mais et là les
gens en fait il transpose pas du tout ce
qui ce qui se passe dans le milieu
sportif ou et c'est là où je pense que
le PS elle a la vraiment un rôle très
important à jouer parce qu'en fait on a
toujours une position un peu bancale
l'éducation nationale il faut quand même
se l'avouer euh on n pas vraiment pris
pour un vrai prof en salle des
profs donc il faut quand même qu'on
arrive à faire ce lien entre l'école et
le milieu sportif alors que normalement
le PS c'est vraiment l'école he mais
mais comme dans l'image des gens ont
fait quelque chose qui où on pourrait
tolérer des comportements qu'on ne
tolérerait pas dans d'autres matières et
qu'on est aussi on a la chance d'être la
seule activité enfin le seul la seule
matière où les élèves
sont pas dans un univers clos assis où
en fait mes collègues ils ne connaissent
pas les élèves mes collègues quand on
arrive en conseil d'être là s's ne
savent rien sur eux ils savent pas qui
se fait harceler par un tel qui vit mal
l'échec qui a des problèmes à la maison
ils connaissent pas du tout les élèves
parce qu'ils les ont en Phe de assis à
30 et que c'est déjà compliqué de faire
cours à 30 personnes en même temps qui
ont des voilà il y a des dyslexiques il
y a des des autistes il y a des des
élèves intellectuellement précoces tout
ça dans la même école qui est génial
hein l'école inclusive mais il faudrait
vraiment qu'on puisse avoir les moyens
mais bon là c'est encore un autre sujet
mais mais nous on peut les voir bouger
on peut les voir avoir des interactions
entre eux et ils sont plus facilement
amenés à venir nous parler donc je pense
que les profs de PS souvent ont une
relation un petit peu différente avec
les élèves et il faut vraiment essayer
de faire en sorte que il soit peut-être
le référent dans l'établissement pour
ces questions-là euh de montrer que la
norme c'est pas de se faire un insulter
et faire une formation aux enfants sur
ça c'est la enfin je leur dis toujours
jamais personne doit essayer de briser
vos rêvres vous dire que ce n'est pas
possible de vous dire que que vous êtes
mauvais que vous pouvez pas y arriver
enfin euh mais euh c'est ça paraî fou
hein parce que c'est moi pour moi la
bienveillance c'est la première qualité
qu'il faudrait avoir pour un enseignant
mais il n'empêche que c'est pas tout le
temps le cas et donc c'est avant même
d'apprendre une matière si on a on peut
pas se construire en tant que futur
citoyen si on n arrive pas à savoir
comment on doit se comporter avec notre
voisin parce que comme on se fait mal
parler bah du coup on parle mal aussi à
nos camarades
euh parce que bon ils parlent pas
souvent hyper bien entre eux hein il
faut mais pourquoi la question c'est
pourquoi c'est c'est aussi essayer de
trouver les origines de ça et je pense
que c'est c'est hyper important qu'on
fasse des passerelles je pense qu'il
faudrait qu'il y ait qu'il y ait des
enseignants de PS qui soit formé pendant
les créneaux UNSS en début d'année et
que après il il redéverse à l'ensemble
de de la communauté éducative et
personnelle qui évolue dans un
établissement et et au début j'avais
pensé d'abord aller dans les
établissements génération 2024 parce que
bon c'est énorme le nombre d'élèves hein
il va falloir que ça c'est une grosse
action mais déjà aller dans les dans les
dans les établissements qui on le label
génération 2024 on est un an des Jeux
Olympiques et que ces élèves là qui font
partie de ce programme qui sont en
section sportive en horaire aménager qui
ont plus de sport que la moyenne dans
leur dans leur emploi du temps ils a
accès à cette formation ça me paraît
absolument
indispensable je voudrais vous remercier
si vous avez des compléments
d'information si vous souhaitez nous
solliciter à niveau à nouveau à l'écrit
ou à l'oral vous n'hésitez pas sera avec
grand plaisir nous sommes quelquesuns à
faire partie également de de la
commission éducation culture et le sport
donc nous n'oublierons pas de revenir
vers vous pour avoir des propositions
concrètes et et on se donnera suite en
tout
cas longue vie à
rebond même si je souhaite qu'on en ait
plus jamais besoin mais en tout cas un
message comme ça positif et d'éducation
au sein des collectivités au sein des
clubs des fédérations il est
nécessaire on parle dans le domaine du
sport mais vous l'avez dit dans tout
domaine d'activité c'est grandement
nécessaire qu'on ait cette éducation
et et que quand vous témoignez comme ça
avec cette sincérité sur votre parcours
personnel et bien j'espère que ça
servira également à à éviter des
situations d'autres situations critiques
à prévenir que nos enfants puissent
pratiquer du sport dans de bonnes
conditions je vous remercie beaucoup du
fond du cœur merci
beaucoup